هدوء تامون في هذه الساحه بالكويت قبل
موعد انتخاب البرلمان الجديد
لم يكن الامر كذلك قبل اقل من عام
فقد كانت تعج بناخبي وانصاري احد المرشحين
اختار المرشح هذه المره مكانا غير تقليديا
لحملته الانتخابات مجلس الامه
وكذلك فعل اخرون
ركن المرشحون الى اساليب ومواقع متعدده
لاستماله اصوات ناخبين كزياره مؤسسات
المجتمع المدني والدواوين وتنظيم مؤتمرات
انتخابيه وندوات المفهوم المطر الانتخابي
صار اليوم يعني مع التواصل الاجتماعي ثابت
الفكره وصارت يعني مو من الاولويات مثل ما
كان في سابغه انت قاعد تتكلم عن تجربه من
62 غابه المقر التقليديه وحضرت تلك
الافتراضيه
شكل جديد في التواصل مع الناخبين اتخذته
مرشحه منبرا لعرض برامجها ولقاء ناخدها
افتراضيا بجهد ابسط وتكلفه اقل في
[موسيقى]
اضحت هذه الشاشه تغني عن اي حضور فعلي
للمرشح في هذه الديوانيه ومثيلاتها
كل ما يحتاجه عيسى هو التنقل في فضاء
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي حيث لا يقل حضور
الشباب عنه في الميدان الانتخابي مع ما
يمثلونهم الثقل التصويطي يبلغ نحو الثلث
الكتله الناخبه
اجتماعي صار مرشحين يوصلوا لك وتسمع
اراءهم وتوجهاتهم بالتلفون يعني مو لازم
تفترق كل واحد حق مقره
بالانتخابات لكن الياس والاحباط يتملكان
كثيرين بسبب الوضع السياسي القائم احنا
ملينا الصراحه نصوت حق ناس ونرفع صيت
الناس بس انا مو قاعد اشوف ولا اي نتيجه
وهو ما يجعلهم يترددون في مشاركه يوم
الاقتراح في انتخابات هي الثانيه في اقل
من عام
المواطن الكويتي يتطلع الى انتخاب برلمان
اصلاحي قوي يتعاون مع الحكومه لتحقيق
التنميه المنشوده والاصلاح
وخشيه ان يسري هذا الهدوء الى مراكز
الاقتراع انتشرت هذه العبارات في دوائر
الكويت الخمس وتحث على المشاركه في
الاقتراع وعدم العزوف عن اداء هذا الحق
الدستوري تختلف هذه الانتخابات عن
سابقاتها فالحملات الانتخابيه لم تعد
تقليديه كما لم يعد تكرار الانتخابات كلما
حل البرلمان او تم ابطاله محفزا على
التصويت لدى بعض الفئات فهل ستختلف نتائج
الانتخابات هذه المره ليعود الانسجام في
العمل بين السلطتين التنفيذيه والتشريعيه
سامعك الجزيره الكويت